the record would pose sunflower is is it
the most streamed song ever all right I
double a certified yeah the biggest song
number wise for sure that crazy I
appreciate that too man insane did you
submit that and and postcard on it later
like what was that process like it was a
normal day you know what I'm saying post
um we hit each other up we want to link
do some work so I pulled up on posters
at electric field he was lit turned up
like always me and post always see each
other and was always like good energy
and then that was it that was like the
third fourth song and then we did a
couple more after that but a couple
weeks later like they played it for the
makers of the movie and they ended up
loving that song and then just post put
his part on there the movie Spider-Man's
like singing along to it and I
think that's the best marketing like a
song can get like something like that
like it's automatically being presented
to this the right demographic you know
I'm saying the kids and they growing up
with the song you know they're the
future of it so they just streaming as
they get older and older I feel like
it's just it's The Melodies you know
what I'm saying it's The Melodies it
feels good it's a bright song you know
what I'm saying it just it just got a
proper look like everything just lined
up perfect